YOU BETTER DUH CALL THIS MEETING
TO THIS
HEARING TO ORDER THE SOME
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS
CALLED TO ORDER.
WE WILL ALSO START IS A
SUBCOMMITTEE UNTIL WE CAN ATTAIN
A QUORUM.
OF WILL MOVE ON TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
MEASURE SOME CONSENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
FOUR SALAS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR A. B.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FOUR VOEPEL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY
SIXTY TWO MAIENSCHEIN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY TWO.
TELLING.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN IS YOUR ONE
THIRTY FIVE THE MOAN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN ACR ONE
FORTY NINE.
CHOI.
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE ACR
ONE FIFTY FOUR VOEPEL.
IT FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN ACR
ONE SIXTEEN NINE MATHIS.
SO WE WILL MOVE FORWARD TO.
IT'S WARM.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE NO NO
WE'RE GONNA GO TO.
.
OKAY FILE ITEM FIVE AB TWO TWO
ZERO ZERO SIX.
I EGGMAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COMEY EUROS
GOING TO BE.
OF.
TESTIFYING IN PLACE OF THE
AUTHOR.
PLEASE MOVE FORWARD.
AND BRING YOUR WITNESSES WITH
YOU PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE.
READY TO GO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
GIVE ME GREAT PLEASURE TO
PRESENT AB. TWO ZERO ZERO SIX
BOB FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN.
I PRESENT TO YOU THIS BILL WHICH
WILL PROVIDE RELIABLE AND CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION TO THE MANY
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS IN OUR
STATE.
MUCH OF CALIFORNIA SUCCESS AS
THE SIXTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD CAN BE ATTRIBUTED TO ITS
BOOMING AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY.
NONE OF THIS WOULD BE POSSIBLE
WITHOUT CALIFORNIA'S HARD
WORKING AGRICULTURAL LABOURS.
THESE LABORS WORK LONG HOURS IN
EXTREME TEMPERATURES AND
CONDITIONS TO KEEP THIS INDUSTRY
GOING.
THE SAME AGRICULTURAL WORKERS
CAN OFTEN LIVE IN EXTREME
POVERTY WHERE THEY ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
ECONOMIC HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENTAL BURDENS.
MANY OF THE FARMWORKERS MISS
TRAVEL LONG DISTANCES TO REMOTE
WORK SITES BUT STRUGGLE TO
SECURE SAFE RELIABLE AND CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION. THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD HAS CREATED A
VAN PULL PILOT PROGRAM FOR
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS LIVING IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. HOWEVER
THERE ARE OTHER DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT EXIST
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WOULD LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT ALTHOUGH
GRANTS FOR THE EXISTING PILOT
PROJECTS HAVE YET TO BE AWARDED
OTHER VAMP POLLS HAVE ALREADY
BEEN IN OPERATION AND HAVE
PROVEN TO BE VERY SUCCESSFUL.
THIS BILL WILL CREATE A
STATEWIDE AGRICULTURAL BAND POLL
GRANT PROGRAM TO PROVIDE WORKERS
WITH THE CLEANER MORE RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION OPTION. IT WILL
SUPPORT OUR AGRICULTURAL WORKERS
BY PROVIDING THEM WITH AN
ESSENTIAL SERVICE WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY HELPING TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS BY CUTTING DOWN THE
NUMBER OF VEHICLES ON THE ROAD.
IF IT IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT.
FIELD WORK REQUIRES THAT YOU
HAVE A VEHICLE THAT IS.
RELIABLE IN WORKING CONDITION
AND THEN YOU HAVE TO FIND THE
FIELD THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
WORKING IN AND DRIVE OUT THERE
IT'S FAIRLY EXPENSIVE TO BE ABLE
TO MAINTAIN YOUR OWN VEHICLE AND
THIS WILL PROVIDE A GREAT
ALTERNATIVE.
BECAUSE A BAND PULLS WILL WELL
AND REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
VEHICLES GOING UP TO THE FIELDS
AND A PROVIDE A RELIABLE SOURCE
OF TRANSPORTATION THAT BETTER
MUCH NEEDED. WITH ME HERE TODAY
OUR CAR MARK CORY BOLAS WITH
BOUT CAL BAND AS WELL AS A COW
BANDS WRITER. THANK YOU.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND ERA
PRESENTED PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
KORABL US ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
VAMP AUTHORITY WE ARE A GPA
PUBLIC TRANSIT AGENCY THAT
PROVIDES BOTH GENERAL AND
AGRICULTURAL VAN PULLS. R. AGDAM
PULLS OPERATE IN MOST OF THE
STATE'S AGRICULTURAL AREAS
CENTRAL VALLEY CENTRAL COAST
RIVERSIDE COACHELLA.
AS I AM MS CABALLERO A
REFERENCE MANY OF OUR WRITERS
COME FROM VERY IMPOVERISHED
BACKGROUNDS THEY LACK FINANCIAL
RESOURCES NECESSARY.
FOR CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS IN RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS TO GET TO
WORK EVERY DAY.
IN MANY CASES THE VAN POOLS
THAT WE OFFER ARE THEIR ONLY
MEANS TO GET TO WORK AND DEMAND
FOR THESE SAMPLES IS FAR
OUTPACING SUPPLY.
SO THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
PROJECT ON THIS WERE VERY VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF IT ONCE AGAIN AS
REFERENCED.
IT
CURRENTLY UNDER THE CURRENT
STRUCTURE DOESN'T ALLOW LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES OUTSIDE THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROGRAM.
SO AB TWO THOUSAND SIX WILL MAKE
IT STATEWIDE WILL MAKE ALL
FARMWORKERS FROM LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE ELIGIBLE FOR
PARTICIPATION THE PROGRAMS THAT
THEY TOO CAN ACCESS. A OF A
CLEAN RELIABLE TRANSPORTATION
OPTION AND FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND HE REPRESENTED
PLEASE.
MY NAME IS CUTTING UP A CHUCKLE
AND I'M REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
THEM PULL THE THORNY.
NUMBER OF UNITS RULES.
EVERY A HAVE A QUARTER.
BOB PORTER PORTER WITH MY
HIDEOUS ONIONS.
HELLO MY NAME IS GAVINO KUDOS
AND I'M I'VE BEEN OF WRITING IN
THE VAN PULL FOR ABOUT TEN
YEARS.
I'M AMY WHEN THEY GO FORM OF THE
OF THE WHOLE.
I CAN SIMPLY.
ME BUT A BROKER OTHER THEM VIA
THEIR VIEW HATEM OF WAR EVEN
WITH REPEALCUDDLE SO LONG WE
EAT GOV YET MOST SINGLE
PERSONAS.
UP BEFORE JOINING OF AMPLE I
USED TO WRITE IN MY OWN VEHICLE
BUT WE WILL ONLY FIT ABOUT FIVE
PEOPLE.
CUANDO YOU WANT THELOAN I HIT
THE OF THE EMOTIONAL GOT RUINED
IN PHILI AND. LONG AND THEN ON
THE THE COLLATERAL IS SORT OF A
WE IF WE SIT BY ME.
SOMETIMES WHEN WE WOULD ALL GO
TO WORK.
THERE WOULD BE A LOT OF CARS IN
THE FIELDS AND THERE WAS A LOT
OF MOVING AROUND AND THAT WAS
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR US.
MEET IS IN A BIND THEM LOOK AT
IT THEN A YOUNG MAN A LITTLE AT
THE LYMPHOMA.
SO THEN I HIT THE GOVERNMENT
SIMPLE WE SAID WE'RE GONNA
ALMOST OFFICIAL I SAW THE VAN IN
THE ROAD AND I WROTE DOWN THE
PHONE NUMBER AND I CALLED AND.
EVERYONE IN EVERYONE FITS VERY
COMFORTABLY.
AND I FEEL VERY SAFE AND THEM.
IT.
A BIT EARLIER HANNAH MUMBLED MAN
TO THE MOON SURE. EVEN EVEN
NOTHING WRONG GOOD REQUIREMENTS
TO FIDDLE WITH THEM AND THEN
OTHER YOU DON'T ALLOW HOLE IN ME
THAT OUT OF THE NARROW IMMEDIATE
WIN HIM THE MESSIAH WOULD.
PROVIDING AN EXAMPLE HAS HELPED
ME SIGNIFICANTLY I NEVER HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT WHETHER I HAVE A WAY
TO GET TO WORK OR NOT AND IT
HELPS ME SAVE MONEY. AND THE
PEOPLE THE RIGHT WITH ME ARE
SAFE.
SAY THAT WOULD JUST BUT SO
MARKET THEM AND DO SOME OF THE
ONE QUARTER TO ONE COULD YOU
KNOW.
IN WAS THAT OF EITHER COMMUNITY
IN WHICH SEE ALL. BUT A ROLL BE
HONESTY. IS SOMEWHAT IMPORTANT
MOST ON THE PHONE THE UNIT BUT
NO SUBTITLES.
BUT JUSTICE
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ALSO
USE THE VAN PULLS JUST LIKE ME
AND IT WOULD CHANGE OUR LIVES.
A FOR THE WORSE IF THE VAN PULLS
ONE AWAY THINK YOU.
THANK YOU REALLY TAKE A PAUSE IN
AND.
TAKE ROLE FOR A QUORUM.
NOT SEPARATE TAKE THREE PLEASE
FRAZIER. FONG HERE AGUIAR CURRY.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
CHIU.
DALY. FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
HARPER PRESENT MATHIS
MEDINA.
NAZARIAN. O'DONNELL.
WE HAVE A QUORUM PLEASE PROCEED
DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
ANYBODY FROM THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL PLEASE
FOLLOW.
STATE YOUR NAME AND WHO YOU
REPRESENT PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN ARMSTRONG
CALDWELL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTED
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IS FOR
THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON WILL BARRETT WITH
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
PHOEBE SCENE WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ON BEHALF OF
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL AND SAY HI.
AND STRONG SUPPORTOF THIS
MEASURE.
DO A COUPLE A COUPLE POINTS WE
WORK IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
IN COACHELLA VALLEY. ON AND WORK
WITH.
ORGANIZATIONS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS FROM THROUGHOUT RURAL
CALIFORNIA AND SEE THE NEED FOR
EXPANDING THIS PROGRAM IS VERY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM. AND WE HAVE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE SPONSOR. AND THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR TO TALK
THROUGH A COUPLE THINGS WOULD
LIKE TO SEE STRENGTHENED IN THE
BILL FOR.
COUPLE JUST NOTABLE. ISSUES IS
RIGHT NOW AT LEAVE AS WRITTEN
FIFTY PERCENT OF THE FUNDING
MUST BE DIRECTED TO LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS AND WE THINK THAT.
GIVEN THE ON TARGET COMMUNITY
THAT REALLY SHOULD BE A HUNDRED
PERCENT I'M TARGETING TO LOWER
INCOME AND JUST HOUSEHOLDS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. WE
WORK WITH A LOT OF COMMUNITIES
WHO USE VAN PULLS TO REACH
SERVICES AT THE OTHER WISE
COULDN'T REACH.
SUCH AS HEALTH CENTERS THE
EMBASSY EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AND ARE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT THIS PROGRAM COULD
BE EXPANDED TO ADDRESS
AGRICULTURAL TRANSPORTATION
NEEDS.
A BIT BROADER THAN ON
AGRICULTURAL WORK INTO THAT END
ON THERE ARE SEVERAL
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITIES THAT
WORK IN OTHER FIELDS. ON THE
SIDE COME FIELDWORK AGRICULTURAL
IMPROVEMENT AND I'M IN ALSO
SOMETIMES THE TOURISM INDUSTRY
AND OTHER INDUSTRIES AND WOULD
LOVE TO EXPLORE THIS PROGRAM
COULD.
ADDRESS THOSE AGRICULTURAL
TRAVEL NEEDS AS WELL AND FINALLY
WE REALLY REALLY LIKE THAT AND
THE FACT THAT THIS PROGRAM IS
FOCUSED ON. I'M ZERO EMISSION
AND AND LIKE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
AS MUCH TARGETED TOWARDS ZERO
ADMISSION.
ADMISSION AS COMPARED TO
MINUTES ZERO HOPE PLEASE.
THAT'S IT THAT'S IT THANKS SO
MUCH.
MISTER GIULIANI REPRESENT PLEASE
BY JOSHUA STARK FROM TRANSFORM
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND LIKE TO
LINE MY COMMENTS AT THOSE OF
MISSING.
TERRY SEBERG VETERAN ECO CONSUL
TO ON BEHALF OF AN RTC AND
SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THE
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
WHEN DIFFERENCE TO THE AUTHORS
BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
SO I DO HAVE.
ONE OF THE SPONSOR.
WE DO HAVE OR MOTION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAKER HAVING HER SECOND.
MONTH MR MEDINA WHO HAVE A
SECOND.
HOW MUCH IS A CLEAN VAMP WILL
COST?
AYE. IT'S GONNA VARY DEPENDING
ON THE TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY YOU
CHOOSE BUT. THE ONES THAT WE GO
AFTER SCHOOL GENERALLY AROUND
THE THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
RANGE.
PERFECT.
SO WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SCAPULAR WOULD YOU LIKE TO A
CLOSE.
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SO WILL MISS KELLY ERA THANK YOU
FOR OFFERING THE BILL TO OUR
COMMITTEE IN SUBBING FOR.
MS EGGMAN.
I PLAN TO SUPPORT IT.
AND BUT THINK THIS BILL MAKES
SENSE HOWEVER WE NEED.
HOW WE HOW WE WHEN WE MOVE
POLICY FOR WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE BALANCING OF OUR
PRIORITIES AND INVESTING GIGI OR
IF MONIES WISELY AND
EFFICIENTLY?
AND I SEE THIS IS AN EFFECTIVE
MANNER TO TO.
RACIALLY IN IN THE STATE NOW.
I SWEAR TO MAKE SURE THAT.
COSTING TECHNOLOGY BALANCE OUT
SO THAT WE ARE GETTING THE
BIGGEST BANG FOR OUR BUCK.
HOW WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
WHICH IS PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE?
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE
FONG FONG AYE AGUIAR CURRY.
BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN.
CHAU.
CHU AYE DALY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON.
HARPER AYE HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THE BILL IS TEN OF WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO.
FILE ITEM SAYS YOU KNOW
THROUGHOUT THEIR.
THE THING IS FILE ITEM OF.
THREE.
OF AB EIGHTEEN SEVEN THREE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OVER OBERNOLTE
PLEASE COME TO THE GUYS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN YOU AUTHORED
LEGISLATION THAT CREATED A
VETERANS DESIGNATION ON
CALIFORNIA STATE ID AND DRIVER'S
LICENSES IN THIS IS PROVING TO
BE. A VERY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM IN
NOT ONLY GIVING OUR VETERANS THE
RECOGNITION THAT THEY HAVE VERNE
BUT ALSO IN CONNECTING THEM FOR
TO STATE AND FEDERAL BENEFITS
THAT IN MANY CASES THEY'RE NOT
EVEN. AWARE THAT THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR. IN FACT IT'S
ESTIMATED THAT THIS YEAR OVER
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS OF
BENEFITS WILL BE AWARDED TO
THOSE BUT.
THOSE VETERANS
JUST THIS YEAR AND SEVENTEEN
MILLION AND RETROACTIVE PAYMENTS
IN FACT I ALMOST A THIRD. OF THE
VETERANS WHO REQUEST THIS
DESIGNATION ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
BENEFITS THAT THEY DID NOT
REALIZE THAT THEY WERE ELIGIBLE
FOR.
HOWEVER UNFORTUNATELY NOT A VERY
LARGE PERCENTAGE OF CALIFORNIA
VETERANS WERE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS
DESIGNATION HAS APPLIED AND SO
WE'RE SEARCHING FOR WAYS TO
INCREASE THEIR PARTICIPATION
RATE.
LAST YEAR A. B. THREE SIXTY
THREE.
WAIVE THE FEE FOR LOW INCOME
AND HOW AND HOMELESS VETERANS
FOR APPLYING FOR THE VETERANS
DESIGNATION AND THIS BILL AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY THREE WOULD
EXTEND THAT TO SENIOR CITIZENS.
I SUBMIT THAT.
OVER HALF OF CALIFORNIA
VETERANS ARE SENIOR CITIZENS AND
IF YOUR SENIOR SINCE IN MOST OF
THOSE PEOPLE ARE LIVING ON A
FIXED INCOME IT'S NOT AN EASY
THING ON A FIXED INCOME TO
AFFORD EXPENSE LIKE THIS. AND.
WAVING THAT.
THE FEES TO THOSE PEOPLE WHO
APPLY WOULD BE A FITTING.
AND A VERY A COMPELLING WAY OF
EXPRESSING OUR GRATITUDE FOR THE
SACRIFICES THAT THESE VETERANS
HAVE MADE TO OUR SOCIETY SO WITH
THAT I'D RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
SECOND WITH FIRST AND SECOND TO
HIGH.
MR FORUM THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HARPER BAKER.
SO.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TEST MY IN
SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NINE ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC BUT WOULD LIKE TO.
DESPITE OPPOSITION TO THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NINE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE OF THE AUTHOR.
SO I DO.
BROWN IS THE DMV HERE.
COME THE.
PLEASE.
SO WHILE YOU'RE WALKING A
POSTCARD.
SO THIS.
.
THROUGH THIS PROCESS COULD THIS
BILL WHICH EXEMPTS HALF THE
VETERAN POPULATION. FROM PAYING
THE FIVE DOLLARS TO BE.
RESULT IN A HIGHER FEE FOR THE
REST OF THE VETERAN POP
POPULATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I AM NOT.
JIM WOOD WORD ACTING DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR LEGISLATION INDIAN
THE.
AND OUT WHILE DMV DOES NOT HAVE
ANY OFFICIAL POSITION ON THIS
LEGISLATION.
I DO ENVY DOES NOT ANTICIPATE IN
IN ANTICIPATE INCREASING FIVE
DOLLAR FEE IS THE RESULT OF THE
SLIDES.
SO IF NOT IT IS POSSIBLE TO THE
ENTIRE FEE FOR ALL VETERANS.
I'M SORRY.
IS IT POSSIBLE TO WAIVE THE FEE
FOR ALL VETERANS INSERTED THE
SIXTY TWO. A YEAR TO AGE LIMIT.
ARE AT THIS POINT.
WE'RE JUST.
DOING AN ANALYSIS OF THE
DEVELOP IT'S BEEN PRESENTED TO
DMB.
YOU CAN NEVER.
AND THE REASON I ASK THAT IS A
WHEN WE DID.
NINE THIRTY FIVE.
WE ACTUALLY NEGOTIATED THE
INITIAL COST FROM THE DMP FROM
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS PER
INDIVIDUAL DOWN TO FIVE DOLLARS.
OR WAS GOING TO VETO.
SO.
NOW WE HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY.
SEVERAL YEARS LATER HAS THE
AUTHORS STATED.
THAT.
THERE HAS BEEN SOME LACKLUSTER
PERFORMANCE BUT WE'VE HAD SOME.
SOME SOME.
CHALLENGES IS GETTING THE
INFORMATION NOW.
AND THERE HAS BEEN SOME PUSH
BACK FROM SOME OF THE VETERANS
ABOUT THE FIVE DOLLAR FEE.
BUT THE BENEFITS THIS BRINGS
FORWARD THAT SOME OF THESE
VETERANS DIDN'T REALIZE THAT
THEY HAD COMING BECAUSE OF THE
PROCESS WHERE SERIOUS SO. BRICK
HAS BROUGHT IN MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS
OF REVENUE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ABSOLUTELY MILLIONS AND THEY
HAVE THAT DOCUMENTED.
AND SO. I'M WONDERING AS WE GO
THROUGH THIS PROCESS
FOR THE MOST PART THE BILL
TODAY.
THAT IF YOU WERE WILLING TO
WAIVE FOR THAT SIXTY TWO AND
OLDER THAT WE LOOK AT THE
ABILITY BASED ON THE VALUE THAT
IT BRINGS. BACK TO THE.
THE WE WAVE EVERY DOLLAR EVERY
BIT OF THE FEE FOR ALL VETERANS
GOING FOR NEW TECHNOLOGY. AS THE
AUTHORS STATED.
THEIR SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY.
UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T HAVE THE.
THE ANSWER TO THAT TO INFORM ME
I COULD DO SOME RESEARCH AND
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. GOING AS MOVES
FORWARD AND APPRECIATED AS
AUTHOR GOES THROUGH. THE PROCESS
THAT THAT WE DO BECAUSE WE ARE
ON TIME. OF CONSTRAINTS ABOUT AS
A GROUP MOST THROUGH. BUT I
WOULD. STRONGLY URGE.
.
THIS POSSIBILITY BECOME A
REALITY.
A BASED ON YOU KNOW USING
KNOWLEDGE WITH THAT YOU COULD
WAVE.
HALF THE POPULATION
SO.
WITH THAT I APPRECIATE YOUR.
.
YOUR TESTIMONY.
SO BASED ON THE ADVICE ONE OF
THE COMMITTEE ANY TIME TO.
THIS MATHIS.
I HAVE GOT TO SPEAK OUT IS ONE
OF THE VETERANS UP HERE.
ON LOVE THE BILL.
CARRIED FROM DVD THAT THE
NUMBERS ARE DOABLE AND THAT I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN FOR.
ACTUALLY COMING OUT AND SAYING
LET'S DO THIS FOR ALL VETERANS.
ALL OF.
THEY ARE VETERANS ARE TO PAY THE
PRICE
PERIOD.
SO AS LEGISLATURE'S AND AS A
STATE WE NEED ANY UP AND TAKE
CARE OF THEM.
NO ONE IS SAYING THAT BECAUSE
I'M WHAT I'M SAYING THAT BECAUSE
HE'S GOT PAVE THE WAY FOR MY
GENERATION.
AND WE OWE IT TO THEM SO LET'S
THE RIGHT THING HERE. THANK YOU.
WITH THAT.
I MEAN HE THAT WOULD LIKE TO.
FINISH UP.
YOU I CLOSE UP MANY MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR THE SUPPORT OF THE
COSTS INVOLVED ARE ACTUALLY
QUITE MODEST.
FOR THIS BILL UNDER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND BY
EXTENSION I WOULD IMAGINE IF WE.
INCLUDED ALL VETERANS WOULD BE
UNDER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IT'S REALLY NOT A LOT OF
MONEY IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
BENEFITS THAT THIS PROGRAMS ARE
YOU BROUGHT TO CALIFORNIA SO. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID.
WOULD APPRECIATE IF YOU ADD ME
ON AS A CO AUTHOR IT IF THE DMV
IS ABLE TO.
OF LIMIT ALL COSTS FOR VETERANS
BOB HAVE A TASTE ON THEIR CAVIAR
OKAY.
OF WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM.
SO LYMPHOMA AND.
BY.
HARPER SEKHMET HARPER. MEN
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE COLD
WORLD. MISSION IS TO PASS TO THE
VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE AGUIAR
CURRY.
BAKER. BAKER AYE BERMAN.
CHU. CHU AYE DALY. DELAY I
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON.
HARPER. HARPER AYE MATHIS BY
MATHIS AYE MEDINA. MEDINA INEZ
ARYAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
YOUR TEN IS.
WILL LEAD ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS CAN GRADUALLY SALUTE FOR
TO WORK WITH YOU THANK YOU
MISTER THANK YOU.
SO WE'LL MOVE TO. NUMBER EIGHT
AB TWO TWENTY ONE FORTY FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER S..
GOOD AFTERNOON.
SO MARIN SO I'LL JUST NOTE THAT
YOU HAVE A SUPPORT POSITION.
AND.
.
PLEASE PROCEED THEORETIC.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE TO CLARIFY THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL.
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY FIVE AS A
TECHNICAL BUT IMPORTANT BILL
WHICH CLARIFIES ELIGIBILITY FOR
NEW TYPES OF PROJECTS.
PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED BY BOTH
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION.
AND THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD.
THIS CLARIFICATION IS CRITICAL
IN ORDER TO BETTER FACILITATE
THE DEPLOYMENT OF MIDDLE AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
TO MEET AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS
AND CLEAN OUR STATE'S AIR.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
ALRIGHT THEN I'D LIKE TO CALL.
JOHN BREAUX CELL PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF CAL START.
NO PRESIDENT CEO CAL START I
THINK THERE'S A MOTION I
SUPPORTED.
BERMAN.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
BILL LIKE TO TESTIFIED SERVICE
HERE UP THERE YOU MIGHT AS WELL
WELL OKAY. ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC FEEL LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT THE AUTHORS DO.
SEEING NONE.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD.
LIKE TO OF POSIBLE.
THE TESTIMONY.
SEEING NONE ANY.
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IT AYE VOTE
THERE'S A CLOSE.
SO WE HAVE A HIGH.
WHO WHO WAS THE SECOND?
WHICH.
MR MATHIS IS PURSUING. A MISTER
CHOOSE A SECOND.
A.
THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING THE
BILL AND FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS.
IMPORTANT SUBJECT MATTER.
IT'S IMPORTANT ENSURE PROJECTS
THAT ARE INTENDED TO HELP
FACILITATE THE CLEAN THE CLEAN
GOODS MOVE IT CONTINUE TO BE
ELIGIBLE FUND FOR FUNDING.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE MORE
EMPHASIS ON SUPPORTING GOODS
MOVEMENT AND PHRASING
CALIFORNIA.
SO WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
AND THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
US.
RENTS ARE VERY PLEASE. CALL THE
ROLL MISSION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER ARE FRAZIER
AYE PHAM.
AND WE ARE CURRY.
BAKER. BAKER AYE BERMAN.
CHIU. CHU AYE DALY. DALY AYE
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
HEARTBURN I HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA. MEDINA I'M THIS
AREA.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.THE BILL HAS NINE I
WILL LEAVE
THE ROLL PIN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH THANK YOU
COMMUTING. THINKING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU.
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY EIGHT.
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR ANSWER.
CHECK YOUR MISTER CHAIRS I
MEMBER OF ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF
FOR A. THAT THE AMENDMENT OFF TO
BILL WE ALL KNOW DAD TO SEE
BELLE SAFE LIFE AND CURRENTLY
NEAR NEARLY HALF OF ALL SCHOOL
BUSES IN CALIFORNIA DO NOT HAVE
SI BELT.
THOUGH THE BILL OF SEVENTEEN
NINETY A IS CAME TO CLOSE THAT
GAP BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
AND I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL.
SOME HAVE FIRST BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF MEDINA SECOND BY.
MISTER HARPER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HARPER.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC FEEL
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE AUTHORS DON'T.
THE STATE UNIVERSITY REPRESENT
PLEASE.
I COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
MANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
ELECTED TEST PLANS FOR THE
AUTHOR STILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO SEE
TO.
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SIR PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
WHO YOU REPRESENT. NECKLACE
CHAVEZ ON BEHALF OF THE SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION COALITION WE WERE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL BUT
AFTER THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN BY
THE AUTHOR.
WE'RE HAPPY TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION FROM THE BILL JUST
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE. AND
THEN THE AUTHOR AND THEIR STAFF
FOR ALL FOR WORKING WITH US TO
THIS I REALLY APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU BYE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ANY OTHER
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC FEEL LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NO ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
IT USUALLY TOO UP CLOSE TAKE A
VERY MUCH AGAIN SEAT BELTS SAVE
LIVES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
SO REMEMBER TO THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING THE BILL IN FOR
WORKING WITH OUR COMMITTEE ON
THIS SIDE IMPORTANT SUBJECT.
AND I'M GONNA BICU SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL AND AGAIN THIS IS BEEN
A PASSION FOR YOU AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR DILIGENCE.
I CARE OF MY SECRETARY PLEASE.
CALLED THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE
FONG.
AGUIAR CURRY.
BAKER. BAKER AYE BERMAN BERMAN
AYE CHIU. AYE CHIU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
HARPER AYE HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL AYE.
IS YOUR BILL HAS TURNED ITSELF
NOTE BELOW LEAVE RULE PERHAPS IN
MEMBERS FOR CERTAIN PERIOD OF
TIME.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU. SO IT
WOULD ANY MEMBER LIKE TO MOVE
ANY OF THE ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SUFFERS FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BAKER SECOND FROM. MATHIS.
SO MATHIS ARE HARPER HARPER.
OKAY.
.
I'M SORRY PLEASE KALRA. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FRAZIER.
FRAZIER IPHONE.
AGUIAR CURRY.
BAKER. BAKER AYE BERMAN. BERMAN
AYE CHIU.
TO I DAILY. DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA. MEDINA AYE AND
AS AARON.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
CONCERT KILLERS TO ZERO WE'VE
RULED FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
COLLEAGUES I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
TO AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE THE CLEAN
TRUCK DEPLOYMENT ACT WHICH AIMS
TO CREATE A MORE EQUAL PLAYING
FIELD FOR EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES.
IN THE TRUCK.
TRUCKING FIELD BY ALLOWING ZERO
MISSION IN NEAR ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS TO HAVE THE SAME CARRY
CARRYING CAPACITY.
AS DIESEL TRUCKS.
EXISTING LAW PLACES WEIGHT
LIMITS ON OUR TRUCKS
PROTECT OUR ROADS.
ELECTED TRUCKS NATURAL GAS
TRUCKS AND OTHER CLEAN. VEHICLE
FEW FUELING HIM ON PROPULSION
SYSTEMS.
TEN TO WAY MORE THAN THEIR
DIESEL COUNTERPARTS.
AND COMPETITORS.
AS A RESULT IN ORDER TO COMPLY
WITH OUR WEEK RESTRICTIONS CLEAN
TRUCKS HAVE TO REDUCE THEIR
CARRYING CAPACITY. MAKING THEM
NONCOMPETITIVE WITH DIESEL
TRUCKS.
IN THE SHORT TERM THIS SERVES AS
A DISTINCT. A DISTINCTIVE.
.
DISTINCT A DISADVANTAGE FOR
TRUCK OWNERS TO BUY CLEAN
TRUCKS.
IN THE LONG TERM. AS WE MOVE
AWAY FROM DIESEL.
THE DECREASE CURRENT TO PASS
REQUIRE MORE TRIPS AND THIS WILL
RESULT IN EVEN GREATER
CONGESTION.
AND MORE WEAR AND TEAR ON OUR
HIGHWAYS.
RIGHT NOW FEDERAL LAW ONLY
GRANTS THIS TYPE OF WEIGHT
EXEMPTION FOR NATURAL GAS
VEHICLES ON THE INTERSTATE
HIGHWAYS.
I'M SO I'M WORKING WITH THE
SPONSORS TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
WITH THE BILL.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY CHRISTIAN
MOTOR WITH THE CALVARY TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION.
AND JOHN.
BOTH CELL.
SEE YOU OF CAL STATE TO ANSWER
ANY OF THE QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
WITNESSES IN IN FAVOR ELECTIVE.
IS THAT.
I DON'T.
I THINK YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CHRISTIAN OUT UP
WITH CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION.
WE WANT EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE
FROM THE.
FOR THE MANY REASONS I STATED
BY THE CHAIR.
WHILE TWENTY FOUR STATES.
INCLUDING OUR NEIGHBORS ORGAN
NEVADA ALREADY PERMIT TRUCKS OF
ANY FUEL TYPE.
TOP RATE WELL ABOVE EIGHTY
THOUSAND POUNDS CALIFORNIA'S
UNIQUE AMONG THE STATES IN OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS.
AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE WILL HELP
FLEETS OVERCOME ECONOMIC
BARRIERS TO DEPLOYMENT OF
ADVANCED VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES.
I AS AN EXAMPLE A THIRD
GENERATION BAY AREA TRUCKING
COMPANY.
WHO PLANS TO DEPLOY TEN
ELECTRIC SHOCKS SAID EIGHTY
PERCENT THEIR LOADS WAY EIGHTY
THOUSAND POUNDS?
WITHOUT ALLOWANCES FOR BATTERY
WAIT THEY FEAR THAT THEIR
CUSTOMER SUPPORT FOR LETTER
TRUCKS WILL ROAD DUE TO AND UP
TO THIRTY PERCENT LOSS IN THEIR
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCY.
IN AG COLLAR AND SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY TOLD US TWENTY TO AB
TWENTY SIXTY ONE WILL BE THE
DETERMINING FACTOR IN WHETHER.
HE SWITCHES FROM DIESEL NATURAL
GAS.
I THIS BILL WILL ALLOW TRUCKERS
TO BE ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERS WILL
STILL NOT MEETING THE NEEDS OF
THEIR CUSTOMERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
REALIZE.
MY NAME'S JOHN BRAZIL PRESIDENCY
OF CALCITE WERE A NATIONAL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WITH A
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MEMBER
COMPANIES ALL DEDICATED TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGIES.
YEAH HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES MAKE UP
TWENTY THREE PERCENT. MAKE UP
ONLY THREE PERCENT OF OUR
VEHICLE POPULATION YET THEY
GENERATE TWENTY THREE PERCENT OF
THE STATE'S GREENHOUSE GAS
TRANSPORTATION RELATED MISSIONS.
AND MORE THAN SIXTY PERCENT OF
THE CRITERIA MISSIONS THAT
CREATE AIR POLLUTION.
TECHNOLOGY EXISTS TODAY THAT
REPLACE DIESEL POWERED TRUCKS
AND MORE WILL BE COMING CHRIS
COOLEY BILL OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS.
OUR MEMBERS DO HAVE THESE TRUCKS
IN THE TECHNOLOGY BUT THE ARE
HEAVIER BECAUSE THE BATTERY
PACKS IN THE CLEAN FUEL. A
STORAGE TANKS.
WE DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE REMOVE THIS THIS WEIGHT
BARRIER.
SO THAT THE INDUSTRY CAN MOVE
FORWARD AND AS CHRIS POINTED OUT
TWENTY FOUR OTHER STATES IN THE
DORY ADOPTED SIMILAR PROVISIONS
ALABAMA TEXAS IN MISSOURI ARE
AHEAD OF US ON THIS BUSINESS US
POLICY.
SO WE ARE ENCOURAGED SURE AND I
VOTE FOR THE CHAIRMAN'S AB
TWENTY SIXTY ONE.
BUT THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JUST SHY YOUNG I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL GAS VEHICLES COALITION.
WE ARE ALSO CO SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL ASSOCIATION OF NATURAL GAS
VEHICLE ENGINE MANUFACTURERS
UTILITIES FUEL PROVIDERS AND
OPERATORS WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR FOR THIS BILL. AND.
JUST FURTHER HIGHLIGHTED THERE
ARE TRUCKS ALREADY ON THE ROAD
THAT ARE IN NEED OF THIS
EXEMPTION.
YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSH POND
IN BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA REFUSE
RECYCLING COUNCIL A HUNDRED
COMPANIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN FOR
THIS MEASURE A AND URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE.
MANY OF THESE COMPANIES ARE
WHERE THE FIRST
TO GO OUT AND PURCHASE THESE
VEHICLES
I SENSE THEN SEVERAL COMPANIES
ARE PRODUCING RENEWABLE FUEL OUT
OF THE ORGANICS.
I AND THAT'S ANOTHER BIG STEP.
OF A NET NEGATIVE FUEL UP BELOW
THE ZERO LINE TO HELP THE
ENVIRONMENT SO WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
KAREN I'M MICHAEL SHAW
CALIFORNIA MANY FACTORS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATIONS SPORT AB
TWENTY SIXTY ONE WE THINK THIS
CREATES. AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE ITS
LEADERSHIP ROLE THE SYRIAN WHILE
OTHER STATES HAVE ADOPTED IT.
CALIFORNIA IS THE SOURCE WHERE
MANY OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES ARE
BORN.
DEVELOPED AND DEPLOYED
INITIALING SO WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE CONTINUED CURSE UP.
KELLY JENSEN ON BEHALF OF
PACIFIC GAS ELECTRIC COMPANY.
AND RECOLOGY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
IDEA GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
CUMMINS IN SUPPORT.
THAT'S A LOSS ON BEHALF OF THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
RYAN PARINI WAS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON HAPPY SPORT
THE GERMANS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON RAIN KENNY BEHALF
OF MY COMPANY CLEAN ENERGY AND
OURS THE TRADE ASSOCIATION THE
BIOLOGY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
JOHN CALLED WON'T HAVE
CALIFORNIA WHAT TO
TRANSPORTATION COALITION
SUPPORT.
GAVIN MAKE YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
CAL PORTLAND COMPANY RIPLEY'S TO
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SHAWN AT YOUR WITH CLEAN FLEETS
DOT NET IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TIM CARMICHAEL
WITH SENATOR GAS ELECTRIC AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY
IN SUPPORT.
KURT CAMPBELL JOHN PATHWAYS
CONNECTIONS IN SUPPORT.
A MISTER TURBO PILLAR IN BEHALF
OF TESLA AND UPS IN SUPPORT.
CHAIRMAN STEVE SELF UP PRESIDENT
LOS ANGELES COUNTY WASTE
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION IN SENIOR
COUNTIES POSERS ASSOCIATION AND.
AND ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE VOTING.
FIRST BY MISTER HARPER SECOND BY
MISTER GIPSON. OF WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
YES MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU.
SO OVERLY VEHICLES DRIVE OUR
ROADS EVERY DAY AND IN FACT
CALTRANS ISSUES OVER FOUR
HUNDRED PERMITS FOR OVERWEIGHT
VEHICLES DAILY.
IF OUR ROADS IT CAN HANDLE A
MILLION DOLLARS A MILLION POUND
SPACECRAFT WHEN THE SPACE
SHUTTLE LANDS IN CALIFORNIA.
THEN WE CAN HANDLE THIS
ADDITIONAL WAY AND I'M A GENERAL
CONTRACTOR BY TRADE AND I'VE
NEVER SEEN AN ENGINEER DESIGNER
ROADWAY.
I JUST ACHIEVE CAPACITY
IT'S ALWAYS HAS AN ABILITY TO
ACHIEVE MORE.
SO WE WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS
PARTNER WITH.
CLEAN AIR INITIATIVES MAKE SURE
THAT THE.
THE TRUCKING IN ITS INDUSTRY
HAS AN ABILITY TO BE COMPETITIVE
WHEN THEY BY AND HAVE A VALUE.
AND AND.
INCREASE THEIR THEIR ABILITY TO
HAVE CAPACITY
WITH THAT I URGE YOU RIVA.
AND SECRETARY BUTTE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRAZIER. AYE FRAZIER
AYE FONG FONG AYE AGUIAR CURRY.
BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN. BERMAN AYE
CHIU.
DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER AYE AYE. AYE
MATHIS AYE AYE MATHIS AYE MEDINA
AYE AYE MEDINA AYE THIS AREA.
O'DONNELL. NAZARIAN AYE
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THE BILL MUST WELL AYE VOTES NO.
NO VOTE.
YOUR BILL IS OUT.
TWELVE ZERO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR